why did you get food poisoning connor i
ate a bad sausage i had a bad sausage i
ordered two sausages i cut one up and uh
it was very very pink on the inside
that's a bad sign i thought no i'm not
eating that one but i cut the other one
and it looked okay
yeah you are so susceptible to it i
think since you've been in japan you've
had food poisoning like at least three
or four times yeah from my memory three
times the worst food poisoning you've
ever had
what a lot the
the chest hormone one just one one yeah
that was the worst one you had food
poisoning for a week i was [ __ ] and
vomiting for like a week straight it was
terrible
god i think i've only had food poisoning
once in japan because they serve so much
raw [ __ ] yeah like you know they serve
raw chicken here you know and they say
like oh there's no salmon there is
salmonella there's just way less of it
right there's you're less you're just
less likely to get it it doesn't mean
you can't get you know i'm not being
funny but you should not eat raw chicken
like i don't care if japan is like yeah
it's safe no i've had i've had it before
yeah but it's it's not it's not even
that good it's not that good and you are
rolling a dice yeah you you can eat it
but you are rolling it up well i i had
raw chicken at uh an izakaya that's
specialized in raw chicken because
there's a lot of stuff there's a lot of
izakayas that just like
give it i don't like it
it's a cultural thing right where people
are just like this is safe this is safe
and i'm just like
is it though yeah is it is it safe it's
like you you are eating it and there is
a risk there is of course there's a risk
but it's you know you are unlikely to
get food poisoning from eating the raw
chicken but there is still a chance you
can still get it especially if your
stomach's way more than other foods you
know right yeah but i mean i mean a lot
of things especially in i feel like in
asia which just has a lot of a lot less
standards when it comes to say the
health and safety of the food you
surface
i feel like i feel like even like japan
compared to the rest of asia has really
really good food standards yeah uh
compared to [ __ ] southeast asia oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh my god
compared to the uk it's like japan
doesn't bat a knife it's like pinkish
and i'm like
yeah my chicken's pink in the middle i'm
like oh god
i mean yeah the only time i got food
poisoning was when i went to the
philippines for the first time and uh
you know of all things i could have got
food poisoning from it wasn't the duck
fetus it wasn't even the water it was a
[ __ ] mango shake oh yeah i ate a
[ __ ] mango straight off the [ __ ]
like like street vendor and that's what
gave me food poisoning i'm like cool
yeah amazing it was a fantastic shake
but man i was [ __ ] like i was
pissing out my ass for about two days it
was horrible i think i think the worst
food poisoning i've ever got was uh from
china actually uh when i was still
living there and you know when when you
when you live in china like the food the
food there is [ __ ] great especially
like the street food
but it's just like trying trying to
pinpoint where you've got food poisoning
there is uh
like a needle in a hay it's kind of like
a needle in a haystack like you're just
you're just like what where did the
which one of these food stands did i get
food poisoning from it could be any one
of them could be like a culmination of
all of them
together
i remember it was like so bad that i
almost had to go to the hospital because
i remember it was it was like new year's
eve for like one of the years i can't
remember which year exactly it was but i
remember it was i was sitting on the
toilet and i needed to throw up at the
same time that i was [ __ ]
and
those are the worst
you laughed but like it was a traumatic
what were you just alternating
like i was trying to like keep it in but
that one time one time i literally like
i literally could not like hold either
one so i literally like need this like
well i was sitting on the toilet and i
needed to like try to like aim i can't
listen to this it's it's awful i'm i
don't want to get too graphic
um i've done that before but it's it's
like it was the most awful food
poisoning experience i've ever had
um it's kind of like a seminar south
park
it was like that was that was my
experience
that was yeah say what you will about
fast food chains i've never gotten food
poisoning for a fast food chain i've
never gotten food poisoning from like
you mean like like junk food and stuff
yeah like mcdonald's whatever i've never
i've ever
got i've never gotten food poisoning
from it personally but i have gotten
very sick yeah like i felt bad just felt
like i've never had to throw up after
eating like kfc or
something i don't know about america
i've seen some really ghastly ones in
america i i in the uk and japan i've had
nothing but good experiences no japan is
really good with fast food i think like
the few times that i've had mcdonald's
in america i was like
i feel like i really want to throw off i
feel so i really want to throw this up
yeah it's horrible i don't know how they
make burgers taste so bad at mcdonald's
in america they don't know what they do
i don't know man they're always because
it's because mcdonald's just makes
enough enough money like worldwide yeah
and in america there's just so much
better
uh like
so much better burgers right though it's
more higher end yeah yeah there's way
more competition in america i feel uh i
feel like in america mcdonald's lives
off the reputation of howard
america the rest of the world right